- Wait Sofia, so is it true your husband,
this is like, one of my favorite things,
your husband Joe holds a
Dungeons and Dragons club
in your house?
I mean, these photos, and I actually,
once I heard about this, I actually--
- Do you play?
Do you play this?
- I want to!
I'm such a nerd alert, I literally went
down a little rabbit hole
of watching it on YouTube
of like, him talking about who's
come in and out of the game
and it's the most random group of people.
So this is all true?
- It's super weird, they're really weird.
(laughing)
But it's great, I love it
that he comes and do it here in the house
but now that they are in quarantine,
they're doing it on Zoom,
so they have still been playing.
It's crazy 'cause they can
do something, this game
for like, six, seven hours
and they sing, they clap,
they, I don't know what
they're doing down there.
It's like something really
weird that I can't understand
but it sounds fun.
- You know most people who
play Dungeons and Dragons
don't even meet pretty girls.
To marry one...
(laughing)
- I was like, I love that
you ended up with the guy
that plays Dungeons and Dragons.
- Joe is a complete nerd.
I always tell him that he's
trapped in the wrong body.
It's like they put a nerd in this body
and it doesn't make any sense to me but...
- My man, he's like me.
He's right there with me.
(laughing)
I'm gonna play with him, I'm telling you.
We're gonna do a Dungeons
and Dragons together,
I love it!
- Well you have to, Kelly
and you can come too.
- It looks like a man's club,
it looks like Little Rascals,
like women aren't invited but...
(laughing)
- No, no, sometimes there's been,
no there's been girls
playing here many times.
I mean, it's a small percentage but yes,
they do come and play here.